it's been a push
i'm going to organize my body so that
he's pressing
my back foot down i can imagine that i'm
smashing my own
finger underneath that back foot and i
relax
the shoulder so that the deltoid doesn't
bite
and i don't have the muscle isolation i
can
kind of shake it out just to make sure
and i'm grounding on the back
same thing he's pushing in
i'm smashing my finger on the back foot
i'm organizing my body to relax
and if he lets go really fast you see
how i don't fly
forward because i'm not giving a break
taking his energy and grounding it
on the back foot
you can assist the organization of your
body
as far as the shoulder biting and
isolating
by imagining that you're touching the
wall past
just kind of brushing it with your
fingertips some people find that helpful
but it's more important that you are
really smashing that
foot via his thrusting into your
there's really nothing on the front foot
just grounding the back foot
all right let's try it it is not
necessary
so like if i if i move in here
the grounding is the same and i'm still
relaxing that and organizing my body
so that i don't extend i don't isolate
that deltoid
same thing if i if i move out here i'm
still doing the same thing
okay i i have to
consciously not let the shoulder bite
and isolate so i i relax everything
and i just have the back foot ground me
but you will find it easier if you
organize yourself in a more tactically
minded manner so arms in front of you
not off to the side okay
and not at all that violates
the other weapons okay so
it's a slight bend in the elbow
and the elbow is in but not so much
as you're now exposing the outer deltoid
to a more sophisticated
practice okay so you'll find this groove
here and
from there try these exercises
rounding the back foot stop the shoulder
from biting
arm in front of you this is too much
bend slide spin you can think of it as a
hyperextension
and then a slides bend okay and then
no underneath elbows underneath
and you're up this way okay
he's pushing that changes i don't start
home like this
i don't push it i don't start going like
this
i just stay in that position and all
he's doing is
pushing my heel onto my own finger that
i'm imagining
he's gonna work with me pushing under my
back foot
so he's helping me train for grounding
and i'm going to bend my arm
and he's going to move up the arm so
he'll push on the wrist
replace the hand and then he'll go to
the elbow the slow enough so that
i can reorganize everything
as i need to and he'll come down
and come up to the shoulder with one
hand there you go
okay and then this is out
and he's doing the same thing and then
he reverses
it so elbow slow enough
that i reorganize myself
accordingly elbow
wrists
and the whole time by reorganizing it i
am consciously relaxing
the limb and stopping the shoulder quiet
so he doesn't say anything he's rounding
me
and he'll come up to the wrist
through the elbow and i
consciously relax everything
constantly re-grounding the back
foot consciously relaxing
shoulder okay so
again you can do a quick
we're going to change this drill but the
crystals are all the same so to stop
any chance of a bracing angle and
as you go up this arm okay
this shoulder tends to be a weak point
in most of us and it's actually a loose
corner so as he pushes on it
it starts to turn you that way so you do
have the grounding of the foot but like
i said you have to have the organization
of the body
and you want to think that your
shoulders and
hips move in a connected way
that you don't do that okay so i'm here
like this i just first i want to learn
this homogeneous relationship okay so
we're gonna
we're gonna make that more of a corner
and he'll come down
and i take away that racing when we push
push me push him backwards
that's what you're right okay so you're
pushing me
and i'm gonna do the same thing he's
grounding my
feet
after a while i'll take that energy back
he's just grinding my feet i'm not
leaning
he's making me heavy i'm smashing those
fingers and then
i push out so anywhere
he wants to do a fast let go
i don't go flying do you see so he's
pushing
grounding me grounding me i keep that
shoulder hip relationship
and i push down into my own
degrees
okay he's doing the same drill
and i'm gonna let one side go by if you
have brown
so this side is going by it swallows
into yin
space this side
it's going to hit that it's gonna hit my
right foot
try to just push don't worry you'll fall
fine
doing too much ikea okay push
all right try it okay don't don't make
the
technique
this ikey dominant technique
okay that's the feeling
that's it let the technique
don't be so scared
there you go
oh
that's it you should
like that the
if you keep that arm straight
you see how my body comes up off the
ground
so i'm going
you guys go like this
lower your body
you see that you can do it
never pick
no
there you go keep this arm straight
push push that's it
it's very beginners
so i'm now moving out of the way
that hand is hitting the base of that
same foot
okay
hey
that's it
we started here with the grounding we
moved to here
with the grounding then we moved to here
and now a slight movement ooh
i'm still not doing anything but the
drill
don't start swinging this arm and doing
this
okay it's still a drowning drill
okay
hit boom that's it hit the hard spot
boom
good grip there you go
no boom
that's it okay
so this hand that he pushes here
i'm going to make it boom
he's pushing there
steal that foot
still the homo i don't foot
i know i don't want you to do a geometry
change it's the foot
this foot
all i did was take the hand from here
and i brought it here
all right
okay now this hand just goes
drops like a sword cut
can you add that
each day
hey hi first bro i didn't even move at
all
push please
that's where your ip is your ik is not
in this
yes your ikea is as as his body's coming
in
you're fitting perfectly
this is the drill where i'm out here i'm
trying to get him to push
i'm making him lean it's not just
but the technique is here
almost like you're going chest to chest
can you see that difference so training
way
technique wave
okay
hey
you